game started okay cut quite nice upon as
there this is versus Grandmaster Callen
up is the name um and this is some
Grandmaster duckling playing for the
German champion of baden-baden the
pretty strong grandmasters close to 2600
so not an easy task we've got a bishop a
form Queens gambit now and this is a
fashionable line at the moment on grand
master level it's a very very solid line
for black
I also play it with the black pieces so
it's a bit unusual to have this half
from the white side yeah
this position is known with Bishop e2
and Bishop g4 played
now I get to be careful i think he's got
Bishop c2 threatening
a bit irritated about this position
that's really strange that this son
happens so lonely in the game
yeah i'm just-just them castle should
see two I can't play rook e1 after all
it's it's not little great square but
what is the bishop doing on c2 really
one problem for widest on the weakness
of the B 3 square which might come in
handy for a night and while the queen is
not especially great on default it looks
good in the center of the board but I'd
rather have a night there which would
also protect b3 and c2
I think what he's doing right now is to
to check if he's got any possibilities
to to get some activity for himself hmm
of course he wants to win the game at
least tried to weezer heavily favored by
ratings at 2557 year but he's been much
higher above two thousand six or seven
hundred maybe so he certainly tries to
to find some interesting way to play I
hope is not a disconnect yet it's a
really long thing by not lack forfeits
duty disconnection exactly what happened
to say he he lost he lost this
connection well okay this this is a gain
of 22 rating points but well I'd like to
have seen what what you would have
played here so rather short video um not
sure what black doesn't have any of any
problems he could in terms of just being
equal good for instance always play
along the lines of maybe Bishop c4 and
then 96 and 94 at some point it's very
hard to prevent this and well this
isolated pawn it's not a beauty but
black ass got active piece play anyway
also rook c8 9 p-3 and so on it's um
it's it's very close to equal
disposition I think